Teachers are burning out. Children are struggling to regulate and increasingly whole systems are being pushed to breaking point. But when things go wrong in schools, we often zoom in on individual children instead of asking what's going on around them. I'm Dr. Mariana qualified clinical psychologist and today I'm joined by Dr. Adam McCartney, an educational psychologist who works with schools at a systemic level. Together we explore how educational psychologists actually think about behaviour, burnout and regulation. and why supporting adults is often the key to supporting children. We're using case study examples to unpack what works, what doesn't, and how change really happens.
教师们正在经历职业倦怠。孩子们难以调节情绪，整个教育系统也日益被推向崩溃的边缘。但当学校出现问题时，我们往往只关注个别孩子，而不是去探究他们周围发生了什么。我是临床心理学家玛丽安娜博士，今天和我一起的是教育心理学家亚当·麦卡特尼博士，他致力于从系统层面与学校合作。我们将共同探讨教育心理学家如何看待行为、倦怠和情绪调节，以及为什么支持成年人往往是支持孩子的关键。我们将通过案例研究来剖析哪些方法有效，哪些无效，以及变革是如何真正发生的。
Hope you find it so useful if you do like and subscribe for more. Hi, welcome along to the show. I'm joined today by Dr. Adam McCartney, who is an educational child and community psychologist to give him his full title. Welcome, Adam. Thank you for having me. Thank you for being here. chatting in the DMs, so to speak, for what seems like many a year. And we will come on to think about you and your podcast and the work that you do later in the show. But for now, could you
希望你觉得这些内容很有用，如果喜欢，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，欢迎来到本节目。今天和我在一起的是亚当·麦卡特尼博士，他的全称是教育、儿童与社区心理学家。欢迎你，亚当。谢谢你的邀请。谢谢你的到来。我们私下交流已经好几年了。稍后我们会在节目中聊聊你和你的播客以及你所做的工作。但现在，你能否
give us a little bit of an overview about what an Ed Syke does, if that's okay? An Ed Sykes job is a bit like a piece of string, how long you wanted to be. We have in recent years been almost shoehorned into this assessment process, mostly due to the S-A-N-D crisis. So we do a lot of assessments, statutory assessments. So anyone listening is probably watch the news at some point. There's been a crisis within S-E-N-D. My belief is that we are much more proficient
给我们简单介绍一下教育心理学家是做什么的吗？教育心理学家的工作就像一根绳子，长度取决于你的需求。近年来，由于特殊教育需求（SEND）危机，我们几乎被硬塞进了评估流程中。所以我们做了大量的评估，即法定评估。所以任何听众可能都在新闻里看到过，SEND领域一直存在危机。我的信念是，如果我们能深入挖掘我们对这一角色的理解，我们会更有效率。
if we get to tap into how we see the role. And one of the key things for me is working systemically. So I've spent the last four years trying to get that within schools and hopefully talk about that today. And I believe the power of educational psychology comes when we work through the school systems and the adults that occupy those systems. Amazing. Thank you. I'm also reminded we had an earlier episode on the podcast where we were joined by another
其中对我来说最关键的一点是系统性地工作。过去四年里，我一直试图在学校内实现这一点，希望今天能谈谈。我相信教育心理学的力量在于我们通过学校系统以及身处这些系统中的成年人来开展工作。太棒了，谢谢。我也想起我们之前的一期节目，当时有另一位
child and educational psychologist, Dr. Michelle McDowell. So if anybody wants more of an overview about kind of career journeys and, you know, what that all looks like, check that out at the end of this episode. But today we thought it would be really nice to kind of build on a similar concept to an episode I did with Dr. Joe about occupational and organizational psychologists, where we took more of a kind of vignette approach. So that people are really getting a feel for kind of the nuts and bolts of the kind of problems that an educational psychologist might come up with and how you think creatively to solve those. So you have a lovely Northern Irish accent, but you actually do practice and work in England. And we're talking about kind of state schools, I think I'm right in saying, in England. And so anything we speak about in terms of, you know, standard of education, anything like that,
儿童与教育心理学家米歇尔·麦克道威尔博士加入。所以如果有人想了解更多关于职业历程以及这些工作具体是什么样子的，请在本期节目结束时查看那期内容。但今天我们认为，基于我与乔博士关于职业和组织心理学家那期节目的概念，采用一种更像“小插曲”的方式会非常好。这样人们就能真正感受到教育心理学家可能会遇到的问题的核心，以及你如何创造性地思考来解决这些问题。你的北爱尔兰口音很迷人，但你实际上是在英格兰执业和工作。我想我没说错的话，我们谈论的是英格兰的公立学校。所以我们谈论的关于教育标准等任何内容，
that is we're speaking from an English school perspective and narrative. I think I'm right in saying that you work with both primary and secondary schools, but actually, you know, you work up to 25 years of age. So you're thinking quite holistically about someone's education as well. Is that right, Adam? That's absolutely right. We try to think about the child's journey right into adulthood. And quite often you can't just make that cut off at 19 and say,
都是从英格兰学校的角度和叙事出发的。我想我没说错的话，你既与小学也与中学合作，但实际上，你的工作对象涵盖到25岁。所以你也在相当全面地思考一个人的教育问题。是这样吗，亚当？完全正确。我们试图考虑孩子从童年一直到成年的旅程。通常情况下，你不能简单地在19岁画一条线说，
okay, you're all ready for it. Sometimes you need an extra bit of probation. And that's why we work with people right up to 25 if they need the support. Amazing. And actually when we think about our brain development, you know, our brain isn't kind of considered complete until we've got our full frontal load capacity, which I believe kind of happens around age 25.
好了，你已经准备好了。有时你需要额外的缓冲期。这就是为什么如果他们需要支持，我们会与25岁以下的人群合作。太棒了。实际上，当我们思考大脑发育时，你知道，在我们的前额叶功能完全发育之前，大脑并不被认为是完整的，我相信这大约发生在25岁左右。
So I love that you, you know, you're all geared up to be able to support people until that age. You know, I was very much a different person at age 18 than I was 25. And the way that I thought and interacted with the world and education was different as well. So with no further ado, shall we kind of tackle our first thing? yet. Yes, please. A primary school experiencing acute instability. The head teacher had left suddenly,
所以我很喜欢你能够支持他们直到那个年龄。你知道，18岁的我和25岁的我完全是不同的人。我思考和与世界及教育互动的方式也不同。那么，事不宜迟，我们要不要处理第一个案例？好的，请讲。一所小学正经历严重的动荡。校长突然离职，
early career teachers were close to resigning. Senior leaders were holding risk rather than leading, and teaching assistants were angry and disengaged after feeling consistently undervalued. Moral was visibly fractured. At the centre of this was the perception that the needs of two boys with significant emotional needs, who had become positioned implicitly as the problem. Their distress was being absorbed by the whole system, creating fear, resentment and burnout. Okay, so in this example case study, how would an educational psychologist begin to tackle this problem, Adam?
刚入职的教师濒临辞职。高层领导只顾规避风险而非引领，助教们感到一直被低估，因此愤怒且消极怠工。士气明显涣散。问题的核心在于，人们认为两个有严重情感需求男孩的行为是问题的根源，他们被隐性地定位为“麻烦制造者”。他们的痛苦被整个系统吸收，造成了恐惧、怨恨和倦怠。好的，那么在这个案例研究中，教育心理学家会如何开始解决这个问题呢，亚当？
It's a, this is one of the trickier problems that an educational psychologist will come across because it's not very often you see a full school system in crisis. You'll see aspects of the system in crisis. And what was interesting for me was, It was rooted in these two boys as being the issue. And I simply asked, can I have a look at the whole school? Just let me walk around and talk to people.
这是一个教育心理学家会遇到的比较棘手的问题，因为你很少见到整个学校系统陷入危机。你通常只会看到系统中的某些方面出现危机。对我来说有趣的是，问题的根源被归结为这两个男孩。我只是简单地问，我可以看看整个学校吗？让我四处走走，和大家聊聊。
Because I had a suspicion that's, you know, a head teacher doesn't suddenly just leave unless something's gone awry. And thankfully, they were okay with that. And so what I did is I took a holistic approach. It was like these systems, these different classrooms, although they may not talk to each all the time, they're having an impact on the resources available. And you said in the vignette there,
因为我有一种预感，你知道，除非出了什么差错，否则校长不会突然离职。谢天谢地，他们同意了。所以我采取了整体的方法。就像这些系统，这些不同的教室，虽然它们可能并不总是互相交流，但它们正在影响可用的资源。你在小插曲中提到，
it was visible that TAs were distressed and it was having an impact on them. And they would move around the most within a school. And my first clue was whenever I was walking through the hall and I seen someone crying, that doesn't usually happen day to day. You know, you might get stressed, but you don't get tears.
助教们感到痛苦是显而易见的，这确实对他们产生了影响。他们在学校里走动得最多。我的第一个线索是，每当我在大厅走过时，看到有人在哭，这在日常生活中通常不会发生。你知道，你可能会感到压力，但不会流泪。
So after speaking with them and helping them come around, I got my first nugget. It's like, okay, people are feeling like they have to work outside the remit. People are feeling like they have to work outside their skill zone. So I then went and spoke with each of the teachers, right from reception, right through the year six, and started to unpick what was going on for them. Why was this happening? And there was a few themes that came from that. One of the key themes was several of the teachers felt their skill set weren't being used.
所以在与他们交谈并帮助他们平复情绪后，我得到了第一个关键信息。就像是，好吧，人们觉得他们必须在职责范围之外工作。人们觉得他们必须在技能范围之外工作。于是我去找每一位老师谈话，从学前班一直到六年级，开始剖析他们身上发生了什么。为什么会这样？从中得出了一些主题。其中一个关键主题是，几位老师觉得他们的技能没有得到利用。
most notably there was one teacher who had a really strong background in supporting social emotional mental health she she worked in a prue a pupil referral unit but she was kind of like left to the sidelines because her class didn't cause disruption but they didn't invite her out in order to support the teachers who were struggling and so she felt undervalued and then you had a senko you know special educational needs coordinator trying to try to to hold everything together and trying to find some way to get the teachers on board to support these two boys and it wasn't happening and then you had the TA's you know different levels of skill set different you know some would see themselves as I work with the more able students in order to get them to be the high achievers and others who say I work with those who are emotionally vulnerable taking that more pastoral role and it became quite obvious that the role was not clear And that bred resentment. And some felt that they were having to step into the teacher role without any preparation
最值得注意的是，有一位老师在支持社会情感心理健康方面有非常深厚的背景，她在学生转介中心（PRU）工作过，但她被边缘化了，因为她的班级没有引起混乱，但学校没有邀请她去支持那些挣扎的老师，所以她感到被低估了。然后你有一个特殊教育需求协调员（SENCO），试图把一切维持在一起，试图找到某种方法让老师们加入来支持这两个男孩，但没有成功。然后是助教们，你知道，技能水平不同，有些人认为自己是“我与能力较强的学生一起工作，让他们成为高成就者”，而另一些人则说“我与情感脆弱的学生一起工作，承担更多的牧养角色”。很明显，角色定位不明确，这滋生了怨恨。有些人觉得他们不得不在没有任何准备的情况下承担教师的角色，
or others were feeling like my skill set isn't being valued here. Then I went and spoke with some of the senior leaders. And they were going, I'm senior leader by name. I don't actually do anything differently than the other teachers. But I would like to. And I remember one of the teachers spoke to him about 17 years of experience. It's not ridiculous. Like I was like, surely you being a great position to mentor people and how he set up classrooms and things like that.
或者其他人觉得我的技能在这里没有得到重视。然后我去找了一些高层领导谈话。他们说，我只是名义上的高层领导。我实际上并没有做任何与普通老师不同的事情。但我很想做。我记得其中一位老师谈到了他17年的经验。这太荒谬了。我当时想，你肯定处于一个很好的位置来指导人们，以及他如何布置教室等等。
He's like, I would love to do that. And then we had some teachers who were just on the verge of burnout and disengaged. There was a few nuggets of light in there. You know, there was one teacher who still had the passion for creativity and she had had her children doing all different sorts of things within their learning journey. The thing it took me the most was there was a group of kids outside. drawing on the windows. I thought, oh, what's going on over there? They were doing maths. And I thought, that's brilliant. She's found a way to make it more fun and engaging for them. And so she was very passionate about her role. And then I spoke with, well, the acting head at
他说，我很乐意这样做。然后我们有一些老师正处于倦怠边缘，消极怠工。其中也有一些亮点。你知道，有一位老师仍然保持着创造的热情，她让孩子们在学习旅程中做各种各样的事情。最让我印象深刻的是，有一群孩子在外面。在窗户上画画。我想，哦，那边发生了什么？他们在做数学题。我想，那太棒了。她找到了一种让他们觉得更有趣、更投入的方法。所以她对自己的角色非常热情。然后我与当时的代理校长谈了谈，
that point, who was very concerned about the impact on the community, about the role these two boys, because they got out into the community. These two boys were seen as the problem. And I first thought that came to myself is you can't fix a system in crisis without some stability. And it was a very hard decision that, I mean, I say this in collaboration, but I don't think the school would have acted without my blessing. And it was to take those two boys out and do an intensive pastoral support. So they ended up being taught outside the classroom, which as an educational psychologist is really hard because we really live in Brewery, breathe inclusion, but in order to get back to that point, they had to come out so the teachers could have a bit of respite and stabilize that system. And then it was about using what resources
他非常担心这对社区的影响，担心这两个男孩的角色，因为他们会跑到社区里去。这两个男孩被视为问题所在。我脑海中浮现的第一个想法是，没有稳定性，你就无法修复一个处于危机中的系统。这是一个非常艰难的决定，我的意思是，我是在协作中说出这一点，但我不认为学校会在没有我支持的情况下采取行动。那就是把那两个男孩带出来进行密集的牧养支持。所以他们最终在教室外接受教学，作为一名教育心理学家，这真的很难，因为我们真的生活在包容性中，呼吸着包容性，但为了回到那一点，他们必须出来，这样老师们才能得到一点喘息的机会，稳定那个系统。然后就是利用现有的资源
were available to upskill everyone and steady the ship. So the first thing was get those boys sorted, have two skilled practitioners working with them. One was a very skilled teaching assistant in pastoral support and the other was the Senko herself. which is a big deviation from her role because she'd normally be trying to sort of EHCPs and review cycles. And I had a very tricky conversation with her. Like, if you want to get back to normality, you need to change your role in the short term. And then we looked at the TAs. And it was a case that they weren't having a space for reflective practice.
来提升每个人的技能，稳住阵脚。所以第一件事是把那两个男孩安顿好，让两名熟练的从业者与他们一起工作。一个是牧养支持方面非常有经验的助教，另一个是SENCO本人。这与她的角色有很大的偏差，因为她通常会忙于处理EHCP（教育、健康和护理计划）和审查周期。我和她进行了一次非常棘手的谈话。就像，如果你想回到正常状态，你需要短期内改变你的角色。然后我们看了看助教们。情况是他们没有空间进行反思性实践。
They were very much going from crisis point to other crisis point and just trying to do the best that they could. do. And with the blessing of the acting head teacher, I said, I need some space with these people to have that reflective practice with a skilled practitioner who they can talk to about what they're doing day to day and the impact it has on the children, which meant that then suddenly the senior leader who didn't have a role now had a space to give his expertise and listen to those coming through the pipeline. And so he felt like he was being validated in his space and his practice. And then, you know, the teacher that I told you who worked in the Prue, I said, you need to find some way of helping her feel like she matters in the system. And what they ended up doing was
他们非常忙于从一个危机点到另一个危机点，只是尽力而为。在代理校长的支持下，我说，我需要一些空间与这些人进行反思性实践，由一位熟练的从业者与他们交谈，讨论他们每天在做什么，以及这对孩子们的影响。这意味着那位没有角色的高层领导现在有了空间来贡献他的专业知识，并倾听那些正在成长的人的声音。所以他觉得他在自己的空间和实践中得到了认可。然后，你知道，我告诉你的那位在PRU工作的老师，我说，你需要找到某种方法让她觉得她在系统中很重要。他们最终做的是
making her a senior leader. And I thought, that's a big jump from, you know, you're sitting in corner to do not much to suddenly she she was writing policies and things like that and I went back and reviewed the case and everyone now don't get me wrong there are still issues but everyone was in a better place the Senko looks visibly more relaxed the the teacher who did the Prue work was just you know beaming because although she had extra responsibilities she got the muscle her creativity stuff. The senior leader that I mentioned, he was enjoying his supervision role. And the other teachers just felt like everything was taken care of.
让她成为一名高层领导。我想，这从你坐在角落里无所事事，到突然她开始制定政策等等，是一个巨大的飞跃。我回去复查了这个案例，每个人现在——别误会，仍然有问题——但每个人都处于更好的状态。SENCO看起来明显放松多了，做过PRU工作的老师只是（笑），因为虽然她有了额外的责任，但她可以发挥她的创造力。我提到的那位高层领导，他很享受他的督导角色。而其他老师只是觉得一切都得到了照顾。
Now, those boys still had issues. And those issues, they didn't go away. But they were in a much better place and they were starting to come back into the classroom. And from my point of view, I felt like that was a huge win. because one, I didn't actually do any direct assessment work. I only worked through the people. And what I did was I have my own consultation approach. It's called PIMS, which is psychologically informed management systems.
现在，那些男孩仍然有问题。那些问题并没有消失。但他们处于一个好得多的状态，并且开始回到教室。从我的角度来看，我觉得这是一个巨大的胜利。因为第一，我实际上没有做任何直接的评估工作。我只是通过人来工作。我所做的是我有自己的咨询方法。它叫PIMS，即心理知情管理系统。
And a key aspect of that is focusing on roles. And I was like, how does your role fit within this wider system? How does it lead towards what is considered a shared goal? The shared goal in this case was creating a steady environment for education. and through consultation, I felt like I was able to empower everybody to do something small and meaningful to steady the ship. And for me, that is the power of educational psychology. Absolutely. And you've so beautifully illustrated, actually, I think the ecosystem of a school and how often our problem children can just be.
其中的一个关键方面是关注角色。我当时想，你的角色如何适应这个更广泛的系统？它如何导向被视为共同目标的东西？在这种情况下，共同目标是创造一个稳定的教育环境。通过咨询，我觉得我能够赋予每个人权力，去做一些小而有意义的事情来稳住阵脚。对我来说，这就是教育心理学的力量。绝对是。你非常优美地阐述了学校的生态系统，以及我们的“问题儿童”往往只是一个
the, almost the product of a, of a system that just isn't thriving. And I think what I was picturing is that everybody, other than the lovely teacher who had people drawing on windows, and I would be like, I hope my child gets them as a teacher this year. But other than them, everyone else had had their drive just really diminished, really dipped, you know, if we're thinking about kind of compassion-focused therapy theory, like their drive was absent and it was all just, you know, they're just flooded in kind of, you know, powerlessness and not able to feel sense of satisfaction. And I think that's really, really important, especially when we're looking at careers where people are not being enumerated as much as they probably deserve. And so you need, I think, to be able to get that sense of job satisfaction.
无法蓬勃发展的系统的产物。我想象的是，除了那位让孩子们在窗户上画画的可爱老师——我会想，我希望我的孩子今年能分到她班上——之外，其他所有人的动力都真的减弱了，真的下降了。你知道，如果我们从同情心聚焦疗法理论的角度来看，他们的动力缺失了，他们只是被无力感淹没，无法感受到满足感。我认为这非常非常重要，特别是在我们审视那些人们的报酬可能不如他们应得的职业时。所以我认为你需要能够获得那种工作满意度。
Otherwise, you quickly, you head towards burnout, don't you, Adam? Very much so. and anyone who keeps an eye on the educational news knows that burnout is a really prevalent factor. You know, there was some recent stats that said that 80% of head teachers experience significant stress. And about 60 of those are 60% of those think about, am I burning out? And in my experience, the head teacher, once you see that happening in the head teacher, it filters into the rest of the staff team then. And so, you know, in our in our conversations within educational psychology, there's a big talk about the need for supervision for head teachers at least, designated safeguarding leads and teachers as a whole.
否则，你很快就会走向倦怠，不是吗，亚当？确实如此。任何关注教育新闻的人都知道，倦怠是一个非常普遍的因素。最近有一些统计数据说，80%的校长经历过严重的压力。大约60%的人在想，我是否正在倦怠？根据我的经验，一旦你在校长身上看到这种情况，它就会过滤到其余的员工团队中。所以，你知道，在我们的教育心理学对话中，关于至少为校长、指定的保障负责人和全体教师提供督导的需求，有很多讨论。
Personally, I think anyone who has a professional background needs some sort of reflective space because we're all problem solvers. And in order to be a decent problem solver, you have to know yourself and you have to know what you're about. and I think education has been neglected for a long time. Sure, you know, you're being a clinical psychologist, it's prevalent throughout the NHS that you get decent clinical supervision. And I don't see why education needs to be different from that. I work with some very good community organizations around supervision, particularly for head teachers.
个人认为，任何有专业背景的人都需要某种反思空间，因为我们都是问题解决者。为了成为一个体面的问题解决者，你必须了解自己，必须知道自己在做什么。我认为教育领域长期以来一直被忽视。当然，你知道，作为一名临床心理学家，在整个国民医疗服务体系（NHS）中，获得体面的临床督导是很普遍的。我不明白为什么教育领域需要与众不同。我与一些非常好的社区组织合作开展督导工作，特别是针对校长。
And we're trying to get a research project off the ground. And what we're focusing on is that impact of, does the well-being of a head teacher, translate into the well-being of the school system. Preliminary evidence says yes it does. Definitely. And it's making me reflect that on times when I've kind of stepped in when people have been on long-term sick and I've offered, you know, ad hoc supervision to kind of different disciplines in teams.
我们正在尝试启动一个研究项目。我们关注的是这种影响：校长的福祉是否会转化为学校系统的福祉？初步证据表明是的。绝对是。这让我想起，当人们长期病假时，我介入并为团队中的不同学科提供临时督导的时候。
And they've always just been like, oh my God, this is amazing. Like why haven't I been having this before? It's that level of attumement. It's that level of of safe space. It's not just case supervision, you know, that so much of supervision can be about. It's about supporting that person optimally. And I think, yeah, I think you're right. Everybody in every job where you're kind of working to support others, where that has an impact on you personally and professionally would really benefit from reflective practice spaces. So well done for curating and creating that space for them. And that will, shape them. You know, they may go on to become qualified teachers themselves or they might just stay
他们总是说，天哪，这太棒了。为什么我以前没有得到这个？这就是那种协调水平。这就是那种安全空间的水平。这不仅仅是案例督导，你知道，督导的很多内容可以是关于那个的。这是关于最佳地支持那个人。我想，是的，你是对的。在任何你致力于支持他人、且这对你个人和职业都有影响的工作中，每个人都会从反思性实践空间中受益匪浅。所以，为你为他们策划和创造那个空间做得好。那将会塑造他们。你知道，他们可能会自己成为合格的教师，或者他们可能只是长期留在学校，你知道，那将成为他们文化的一部分，他们也会为其他人优先考虑这一点。所以，听起来那是一个非常棒的投入。做得好。非常感谢。这是一项非常有意义的工作。完美。事不宜迟，我们要不要看看我们的第二个案例研究？好的，请讲。让我们看看第二个。一所大型小学请求为四年级的一个群体提供支持，员工称该群体一直处于不安状态。教师们报告说，班级里存在高水平的低程度干扰、频繁的同伴冲突、注意力不集中以及日益严重的焦虑。午餐时间尤其困难，小小的分歧很快就会演变成泪水、争吵或退缩。员工感到被困住了。他们花费越来越多的时间
long term in a school, you know, and that will become part of their culture and they will prioritize that for other people as well. So, you know, it sounds like a great piece of kind of input there. Well done. Thank you very much. It was a very rewarding piece of work. Perfect. Shall we, with no further ado, have a look at our second case study? Yes, please. Let's look at the second one. A large primary school requested support for a year four cohort that staff described as constantly unsettled. Teachers were reporting high levels of low level disruption, frequent peer conflict, poor attention and escalating anxiety across the class. Lunch times were particularly difficult with minor disagreements quickly turning into tears, arguments or withdrawal. Staff felt stuck. They were spending increasing amounts of time
管理行为而不是教学，尽管课堂实践很扎实，但几个人描述说感到无效和沮丧。人们越来越觉得“什么都不管用”，并担心这个班级被贴上了“困难”的标签。所以亚当，让我们想象一下这个案例已经摆在你的办公桌上了。你会对这所学校、这个班级做什么？这是我喜欢深入研究的案例之一，因为第一，它仍然符合我在第一个小插曲中提到的系统性工作，尽管在扭转整个系统的压力方面没有那么大。它允许你——我们刚才谈到了督导——它几乎允许你通过一个反思空间来进行干预。所以在这个
managing behaviour rather than teaching, and several described feeling ineffective and frustrated despite strong classroom practice. There was a growing sense that nothing works and concerned that the class was becoming labelled as difficult. So Adam, let's imagine this has come in to you across your desk. What are you going to be doing with this school, with this class? This is one that I love getting into because one, it still feeds into the systemic work that I alluded to in the first vignette, although it's not as high pressure in. terms of how they turn around a full system. And it allows you, we just spoke about supervision, it allows you almost to do an intervention through a reflective space. So what I often do in this
场景中，我通常会在观察他们的课程后与老师一起工作。所以通常情况下，有人可能会纠正我，但通常教育心理学家如果去对一个孩子进行评估，你可能会花15到20分钟观察一个孩子。我做的第一件事是花一个小时观察这个班级，以感受过渡是什么样子的，气氛是什么样子的，老师在那一个小时的时间跨度里是什么样子的，你知道，他们一直都很冷静吗？是否有行为爆发，他们是如何应对的？助教和老师之间的动态是什么？他们使用什么样的沟通方式？
scenario is I work with the teacher after observing their lesson. So typically, someone might correct me on this, but typically an educational psychologist, if they're going into doing an assessment on a child, you might spend 15 to 20 minutes observing a child. The first thing I do is spend an hour, observing this class to get a feel for what the transitions look like, what the atmosphere is like, what the teacher is like across that hour span, you know, are they pretty chill the whole time? Is there a flare-ups of behaviours and how they respond to it? What is the dynamics between the teaching assistants and the teacher? And what sort of communication methods are they using?
他们依赖口头交流吗？他们依赖很多小的结构化干预或过渡吗？还是他们严重依赖视觉交流，比如PPT、计时器和视觉时间表，只是为了感受一下，而不是从评判的角度。不同的班级需要不同的东西。然后我会把老师带出来，假设他们能找到代课老师，我会和他们进行一次非常深入的谈话。我在我告诉你的PIMS模型中使用的一个框架是如何赋予老师权力。
Do they rely on verbal communication? Do they rely on lots of little structured interventions or transitions? or do they rely heavily on visual communication, things like PowerPoints and timers and visual timetables, just to get a feel for it, not from a judgmental point of view. Different classes need different things. And then I would take the teacher out, assuming that they can get supply teaching in place, and I would have a really in-depth conversation with them. And one of the frameworks I use within the PIMS model that I told you about is how to empower a teacher.
所以我们关注控制、角色和身份。我们从身份开始，因为那是你成为老师的旅程。所以这是简单的问题：是什么让你进入教学行业的？你的旅程是什么样的？你喜欢你的教学实践吗？你有很多反思性实践的机会吗，还是我们被扔进了深水区？我们现在知道，进入教学行业大约有四五种不同的主流途径。我交谈过的大多数老师都是通过PGCE（教育学研究生证书）途径。
So we look at control, role and identity. And we start off with identity because that is the journey of how you became a teacher. So it's simple questions of what made you get into teaching? What was your journey like? Did you enjoy your teaching practice? Did you have many opportunities for reflective practice or we kind of thrown in the deep end? We know nowadays that there's about four or five different mainstream journeys into teaching. Most teachers I speak to go through the PGCSE.
然后还有直接学校途径，我想是迈克尔·戈夫引入的。然后你有传统的，我要去拿一个大学学位，一个教学入门。这些不同的旅程有不同的好处、优势和技能组合。我让他们反思他们真正擅长什么。你觉得你作为老师的角色有什么强大的地方？你又在什么方面感到挣扎？
PGCE route. And then there's also direct school, I think it's called, brought in by Michael Gove. And then you've got the traditional, I'm going to go and get a university degree, a teaching introduction. And those different journeys have different benefits and strengths and skill sets. And I get them to reflect on what they're really good at. What do you find that's strong about your role as a teacher? and what do you struggle with?
现在，大多数通过快速通道或更快通道场景的老师往往在SEND方面感到挣扎，因为你必须进入一个不能典型地处理信息的学生的思维模式。这很困难，特别是如果你没有——在我的情况下，我有超过15年的心理学背景。
Now, most teachers who go through the fast track or faster track scenarios tend to struggle with the S-E-N-D side of things because you have to get into the mindset of a student who doesn't process information typically. And that's difficult, especially if you don't have, you know, in my case, I've got over 15 years of psychological background.
我想问你，玛丽安，你有多少，只是为了礼貌。这对一个人解决问题的能力产生的影响可能是深远的。同样，我们谈到了督导。大多数老师没有机会获得高质量的督导。所以他们没有机会反思他们作为问题解决者的技能。所以这是第一个这样做的空间。所以这就是身份要素。
I want to ask you, Marion, how much you've got, just to be polite. and the impact that can have on one's ability to problem solve can be profound. Again, we said about supervision. Most teachers don't get the opportunity for high quality supervision. So they don't get to reflect on their skills as a problem solver. So this is the first space to do that. So that's the identity element.
然后角色是，你应该做什么？就像，你应该对这些难以处理信息的孩子做点什么吗？还是这是别人的问题？一旦你开始经历那个旅程，让他们思考，实际上，也许我应该对他们做点什么，然后他们可能能够留在教室里，而不是推迟给SENCO
And then the role is, what should you be doing? Like, should you be doing something with these kids who struggle to process information? or is it someone else's problem? And once you start to go through that journey and get them to think about, actually, maybe I should be doing something with them and then they might be able to stay in the classroom rather than deferring to the Senko
或校长或助理校长，他们开始思考，好吧，如果我重组班级，如果重组座位安排，我可以开始与这些孩子一起工作。最简单的方法之一，因为人们倾向于通过经验更好地吸收心理学信息，是我帮助他们建立一个过渡计划。我做的一件事是我为全班方法调整了“调节区域”。
or the head teacher or the assistant's head, they start to think about, okay, if I restructure the class, if restructure the seating plan, I can start to work with these kids. One of the simplest ways to do, because people tend to absorb psychological information better through experience, is I help them set up a transition plan. One of the things I do is I've adapted the zones of regulation for a whole class approach.
我对他们说，这会占用很多时间，但这是理解班级情感素养和情感需求的一种非常非常有用的方法。就是在房间的角落里放四种不同的颜色，假设你没有一个三角形的房间，但你放了四种不同的颜色。绿色是给那些感到调节良好并准备好进行下一个学习主题的孩子。黄色是给那些感到有点傻或有点
And I say to them, this is going to take up a lot of time, but it's a very, very useful method for understanding the emotional literacy and the emotional needs of your class. and it's where you put four different colors on the corner of the room, assuming you don't have a triangular room, but you put four different colors on. And green is for those children who feel regulated and ready for the next learning topic. Yellow is for those who are feeling a bit silly or a bit,
不是失调，但在边缘的孩子，蓝色是给那些感到情绪有点低落的孩子。红色，这是关键部分。红色是给那些处于失调或愤怒边缘的孩子。我对老师说，好吧，你有针对黄色、蓝色和绿色的独立策略。所以绿色通常是基于课程的。我要和同伴谈论历史。我要读一本基于课程的书。
not dysregulated, but on the verge of it and blue is for those who are feeling a bit low mood. And red, this is the key bit. Red is for those who are on the verge of dysregulation or anger. And I say to the teacher, okay, you have independent strategies for yellow, blue and green. So green is usually something curriculum based. I'm going to talk about history with a peer. I'm going to read a book that's curriculum based.
你知道，一些没有要求，但稍微令人愉快的事情。然后黄色和蓝色是基于感官的或基于情感素养的。所以它可能是关于谈论他们的感受。对一个值得信赖的同伴或一个可用的助教。或者它可能是，我要做一些靠墙坐。我要做一些推墙运动，或者我要做一些不分散注意力，但感官调节的事情。然后我是红色那个，这是给那些难以保持调节的孩子，
You know, something that's no demand, but slightly enjoyable. And then yellow and blue are century based or emotional literacy based. So it might be about talking about how they feel. to a trusted peer or to a TA or teaching assistant who's available. Or it might be, I'm going to do some wall sets. I'm going to do some wall pushes or I'm going to do something that's not distracting, but century regulating. And then I'm the red one, which is for those kids who are struggling to stay regulated,
他们和老师坐在一起，而且必须是老师。教室不幸的事情是每个孩子都知道教室的等级制度。他们知道老师是教室的领导者。如果教室的顶端，领导者关心你，你更有可能在这一天保持调节。这是它向他们展示的第一件事。就像，我在乎你。我给你时间。他们坐下来和我谈话。
they sit with the teacher and it has to be the teacher. The unfortunate thing about classrooms is every child knows the hierarchy of the classroom. They know the teacher is the leader of the classroom. And if the top of the classroom, the leader, cares about you, you're more likely to stay regulated throughout today. And this is the first thing it shows them. It's like, I care about you. I'm giving you time. They sit and talk to me.
那位老师学会给他们词汇以及如何调节。他们也和他们坐在一起。我们知道成年人的冷静有助于孩子冷静。我对老师说，你必须接受你作为“第三家长”的角色。除了妈妈和爸爸，通常是妈妈和爸爸，你是他们一周中花时间最多的人。通常，当然有例外。不仅如此，那个孩子随后感到被调节、被接受和被关心，但那些有点摇摆不定，但没有到破坏性程度的其他孩子，对自己说，那位老师关心我们所有人，因为他或她在为最
And that teacher learns to give them the words and how to regulate. They're also sitting with them. And we know the adults calm helps the child be calm. and I say to teachers, you've got to accept your role as the third parent. Other than mommy and dad, typically mommy and daddy, you're the person they spend the most time with during the week. Usually, obviously there's exceptions. And not only that, that child then feels regulated and accepted and cared for, but the other children who are a little bit wobbly, but not to the point with the disruptive, say to them, themselves, that teacher cares about all of us because he or she is taking the time for the most
棘手的学生花时间。如果我成为最棘手的学生，我知道他们会照顾我。这些事情有我们所说的“软系统影响”，它们过滤掉，每个人的情绪都开始平静下来。起初投入很大，但随着时间的推移，老师，那些过渡变得更快。老师得到了他们渴望的越来越多的教学时间。关于这一点最好的事情是，我已经在大约10到15所学校做了这个。其中大约三分之一正在经历Ofsted（英国教育标准局）窗口期。他们都回来反馈说，这被强调为提高情感素养的良好心理实践。
tricky student. If I become the most tricky student, I know they will take care of me. And those things have soft, what we call soft systems impact, whereby they filter out and everybody's mood just starts to calm down. And it's heavy investment in the beginning, but as time moves on, that teacher, those transitions become quicker. And the teacher gets more and more back of the teaching time that they crave. And the best thing about this, I've done this across about 10 to 15 schools now. And about third of them are going through the Ofsted window. And they've all come back as this was highlighted as good psychological practice that improves emotional literacy.
所以任何听众如果是老师，Ofsted喜欢这些东西。所以如果什么都没有，至少它给了你那个。我喜欢那个。所以孩子们在任务或活动结束时身体上移动到那些不同颜色的角落。所以，你知道，思考是否你已经完成了，你知道，你的书，你的小组讨论，然后在每次活动结束时你都在说，好吧，是时候去我们的角落了。让我们选择我们在哪里。这就是实际运作的方式吗？如果他们即将去休息，你给多长时间，亚当？所以它又是那种“长度取决于绳子”的事情。他们必须做的第一件事是他们必须教他们这个系统。所以老师必须投入时间说，这就是我们将如何进行过渡。他们必须选择最好的时间来做这件事。
So anyone listening who's a teacher, Offstead loves this stuff. So if nothing else, at least it gives you that. I love that. So the kids are physically moving around to those different coloured corners at the end of, at the end of a task or activity. So, you know, thinking about whether you've done, you know, your book, your group discussion and then literally at the end of every activity you're saying, right, it's time for our corners. Let's pick where we're at. Is that how it works practically? And how long, you know, if they're about to go out to break, how long do you give that, Adam? So it again is one of those things that's along as a piece of string. The first thing they have to do is they have to teach them the system. So the teacher has to dedicate time to be like, this is how we're going to do our transitions. And they have to pick the best time to do that.
我所说的是，你为认知负荷变化或环境变化进行过渡。所以环境变化是从休息时间进来，正如你提到的。负荷变化是当你从，比如，英语转到数学时，因为对一些孩子来说，那是一个容易的过渡。对其他人来说，那是世界的尽头，因为他们绝对讨厌数学，他们需要一些签到。随着时间的推移，你通常，你可能能够放弃一些认知负荷变化。比如从数学转到艺术对班级来说可能不是什么大不了的事，所以他们说，好吧，没关系，我们可以放弃那个。但你会随着时间的推移学到这一点。如果你一直做到那个坐在红色的最后一个孩子，所以说，
And what I said in is you do the transition for a cognitive load change or an environmental change. So an environmental change is coming in from break time, as you alluded to. A load change is when you're going from, say, English to maths, because for some kids, that's an easy transition. For others, that's the end of the world because they absolutely hate maths and they need some check-in. And as time goes on, you can usually, you might be able to drop some of the cognitive load changes. Like going from maths to art might not be a big deal for the class, so they go, well, it's fine, we can drop that one. But you will learn that over time. If you do it until the kid, the last kid who sits at red, so say, for
三个孩子和老师坐在一起。一旦第三个孩子准备好回到课程，那么过渡就结束了。这就是规则。这对一些老师来说可能很难接受，因为他们在想，我在课程进度上落后得越来越多。可悲的现实是你会在课程进度上落后得越来越多。
three children are sitting with the teacher. Once that third kid is ready to return to the lesson, then the transition's over. That's the rule. And that can be difficult for some teachers to swallow because they're thinking, I'm falling further and further behind with the curriculum. The sad reality is you're going to fall further and further behind with the curriculum.
如果你不这样做，因为这是一个时间投资，它不是一个快速修复。你是在展望春季和夏季学期，理论上你会把时间赚回来，你的教学会更到位，用一个更好的词来说。这就是你管理过渡的方式。我很想成为这些，你知道，这些角落练习中的一只苍蝇。听起来太强大了。在思考一点关于心理学和行为强化，我可以看到关于
If you don't do this, because this is a time investment, it's not a quick fix. You're looking to the spring and summer terms and theory that you will get that time back and your teaching will be much more on point for lack of a better term. And that's how you manage the transitions. I would love to be a fly on the wool for one of these kind of, yeah, one of these corner exercises. It sounds so powerful. In thinking a little bit about kind of psychology and behavioral reinforcement, I could see that one argument about
为什么不这样做的一个论点可能是，实际上我会选择红色，因为我想要和老师在一起的时间，然后那会被强化，或者我会发脾气，因为我想要和我最喜欢的老师在一起的特殊时间，或者我已经一周没见到他们了。你能为我们解释一下为什么最终希望那不会发生吗，亚当？第一件事是反转问题，如果那确实发生了，那是一件坏事吗？因为如果你想要和老师在一起的时间，你想要感到和一个成年人亲近。你想要感到你和他们有关系。那个孩子很可能还有其他潜在的情感需求。
why not to do this might be that actually I'm going to choose red because I want that time with my teacher and then that will be reinforced or I'm going to kick off because I want that special time with my favourite teacher or I've not seen them for a week. Like could you talk us through why ultimately hopefully that doesn't happen Adam? The first thing is to flip the question is if that does happen, is that a bad thing? Because if you want time with the teacher, you want to feel close to an adult. You want to feel like you have a relationship with him. The chances are that child has some other underpinning emotional need.
而且其他可能性是你将能够非常快地管理那个过渡。如果你试图竖起障碍，就像我知道你必须去这个角落，那么那个孩子感到被拒绝，这违背了它的整个目的。孩子必须感到被接受。这可能就像，你知道，一个击掌。如果年幼的孩子可能需要一个拥抱。然后老师只是说，好吧，你觉得你现在被调节好了吗？
And the other chances are you'll be able to manage that transition very quickly. And if you try to put up the barriers, as I know you must go to this corner, then that child feels rejected, which defeats the whole purpose of it. The child has to feel accepted. And it could be as simple as, you know, a high five. if younger kids might need a cuddle. And then the teacher just says, okay, you feel like you're regulated now.
你觉得你准备好回到学习了吗？去吧。他们有了那种联系。这就是孩子们在寻找的。他们在寻找那种联系。如果你从神经学上观察他们，对于难以调节的孩子，我脑子里总是有三件事。
You feel like you're ready to return to learning. Go on. And they've had that connection. And that's what children are looking for. They're looking for that connection. And if you look at them neurologically, there's always three things that I always have in my mind for children who struggle to regulate.
那就是感官发展、语言发展和关系发展。如果他们正在寻求关系方面的东西，可能就给他们，因为他们不觉得被调节或者他们觉得奇怪。这对我们来说可能不明显。但问题是，如果你给他们那种关心，你更快回到课程。谢谢。那太不可思议了。
And that's century development, language development, and relational development. And if they're seeking out the relational stuff, probably give it to them because they don't feel regulated or they feel funny. It might not be obvious to us. But the thing is you're quicker to get back to the lesson if you give them that, that you care. Thank you. That's incredible.
这就是世纪发展、语言发展和关系发展。如果他们正在寻求关系方面的东西，那就给他们，因为他们可能感觉不到被调节，或者感觉很奇怪。这对我们来说可能并不明显。但关键是，如果你给他们这些，让他们感受到你的关心，你就能更快地回到课程中。谢谢你。这太不可思议了。
And it reminds me, if anyone's interested in this kind of approach and this way of thinking about attachment, there's a really wonderful book. Well, I think it's wonderful. That's I'll ask your opinion on it if you've read it by Gabe or Matte called Hold On to Your Kids. And it's really, really lovely. It's about the idea of emotional collection. And that applies to schools and education, but also us to, me as a parent,
这让我想起，如果有人对这种方法以及这种关于依恋的思考方式感兴趣，有一本非常棒的书。嗯，我觉得它很棒。如果你读过的话，我会问问你的看法，那是加博·马特（Gabe Mate）写的《抱住你的孩子》（Hold On to Your Kids）。它真的非常非常可爱。它讲的是情感联结的概念。这不仅适用于学校和教育，也适用于我们，比如我作为一名家长，
are we emotionally collecting the children that we're around or are we just expecting them to respect us and follow our rules? And I really love that idea. Is that a book you're familiar with Adam? No, but I'm starting to feel like I'm repeating what they've said. I swear I haven't stolen their ideas. Shows that you know what you're talking about. And, you know, it's a nightmare when someone says,
我们是否在情感上与我们周围的孩子建立了联结，还是仅仅期望他们尊重我们并遵守我们的规则？我真的很喜欢这个想法。亚当，你熟悉这本书吗？不，但我开始觉得我在重复他们说过的话。我发誓我没有窃取他们的想法。这说明你很了解你在谈论什么。而且，你知道，当有人说，
there's this great book. You know, have you read it? You're like, no. It doesn't say anything about it. You haven't because you're already talking the talk and walking the walk. But I think if anyone else is interested in this and they're not already in Ed Syke,
有一本很棒的书。你知道吗，你读过吗？你会说，没有。这并不代表什么。你没读过是因为你已经在践行这些理念了。但我认为，如果还有其他人对此感兴趣，而且他们还不是教育心理学家，
they might well find it helpful to listen to that or to read a copy. I was telling you before we hit record, I tend to listen to kind of workbooks, whereas actually you very much more prefer fact books and reading those, reading those. So we're all different, aren't we? And actually, maybe as students, we'd have been different as well. It's just that I think the world wasn't quite as accessible when I was growing up. I'm 42 at the time of recording. And had I been able
他们可能会觉得听听那个或者读一读副本很有帮助。我在录音前就跟你说过，我倾向于听那种工作手册，而实际上你更喜欢事实类书籍并阅读它们。所以我们每个人都是不同的，不是吗？事实上，也许作为学生，我们也会有所不同。只是我觉得在我成长的过程中，世界还没有那么容易获取信息。在录制时我42岁。如果我能
to listen to things more, that would have helped me loads, but it just wasn't. But I think we're doing better now. We know better. I think you're absolutely right. We definitely know better. And the world is much more accessible. And I know we've gone through our two big nets, but the big thing that's coming through the pipeline is what does education look like in the world of AI? And teachers are trying their best to unpick what that looks like. You know, the number of times I've gone on the school conferences, and there's one teacher who's been pegged with, I've got to do the AI session.
更多地听这些内容，那会对我有很大帮助，但当时并没有。但我认为我们现在做得更好了。我们知道得更多了。我想你是完全正确的。我们确实知道得更多了。世界也变得更加触手可及。我知道我们已经讨论了两个大话题，但目前最重要的事情是，在人工智能时代，教育会是什么样子？老师们正在尽最大努力去剖析那会是什么样子。你知道，我参加过多少次学校会议，总有一位老师被指派说，我必须做人工智能环节。
I don't know what I'm doing. And I feel for them because nobody really knows what they're doing when it comes to AI or what it's going to look like. But the bottom line is it's going to have some sort of impact. And what people don't realize, or not everyone realizes, is that relationships actually still are core to our journey through life, our journey through education. And so although we're bringing in this tool that's very fantastical and shiny,
我不知道我在做什么。我为他们感到难过，因为当涉及到人工智能或它未来会是什么样子时，没有人真正知道自己在做什么。但底线是它会产生某种影响。人们没有意识到，或者不是每个人都意识到的是，人际关系实际上仍然是我们人生旅程、教育旅程的核心。所以，尽管我们引入了这个非常奇妙且闪亮的新工具，
you still need those relationships. And that's why everything I talk about is learning through connection, collaboration. These are the key, these are going to become the core skills next to literacy and numeracy, because this is how you access not only the workplace, but the learning environment. This is how you come up with new ideas. No matter how good AI gets, the human ability to be creative is unparalleled. And if we create an education system that matches that creativity and that need for connection, then we're onto something that's, in my view, beautiful.
你仍然需要那些人际关系。这就是为什么我谈论的一切都是通过联结和协作来学习。这些是关键，这些将成为继读写能力和算术能力之后的核心技能，因为这就是你不仅进入职场，而且进入学习环境的方式。这就是你提出新想法的方式。无论人工智能变得多么好，人类创造的能力是无与伦比的。如果我们创造一个与这种创造力和联结需求相匹配的教育系统，那么在我看来，我们正在做一件美丽的事情。
Adam, it's amazing. I could talk to you for hours. Your curiosity, your compassion, your kindness, and your passion for what you do just radiates out of you. So it's absolutely lovely. I've loved today. Could you tell us a little bit about your new podcast that you've launched? Yes.
亚当，这太棒了。我可以和你聊上几个小时。你的好奇心、同情心、善良以及对你所做工作的热情简直从你身上散发出来。所以这绝对太可爱了。我很喜欢今天。你能给我们介绍一下你新推出的播客吗？是的。
Thank you for asking that. It's called Between Two Sykes with myself, Dr. Adam McCartney and Mike Lane, who's my co-host. And we met in a local authority when we were both working in the north of England. and we just stayed in touch. And as the years went past, we started to think, there's not a podcast that's out there that supports teachers in the way that we would support.
谢谢你的提问。它叫《两个心理学家之间》（Between Two Psychs），由我和我的联合主持人迈克·莱恩（Mike Lane）共同主持。我们在英格兰北部的地方政府工作时相识，然后一直保持联系。随着岁月的流逝，我们开始思考，市面上没有一个播客能以我们想要支持的方式来支持老师们。
So we put our heads together and we decided we need to do this. And we came up with between two psychs. And the whole remit of it is that we want to give digestible psychology that teachers and abutting educational psychologists can use in their practice. So we talk about things like identity, we talk about things like burnout, we talk about things like what we call challenging behavior. And, you know, those who are interested in neurodiverse conditions, the first three episodes are dedicated to how school systems work around that from the child right through to the parents and leadership. So we try our best to pick topics that are relevant to educational settings and give little nuggets of, psychology that are applicable and can be applied without having to open up a million textbooks.
所以我们集思广益，决定做这件事。我们想出了《两个心理学家之间》。它的全部宗旨是，我们想提供易于消化的心理学知识，让老师和准教育心理学家可以在实践中使用。所以我们谈论身份认同、职业倦怠，以及我们所谓的挑战性行为。而且，你知道，那些对神经多样性状况感兴趣的人，前三集专门讨论学校系统如何围绕这一点运作，从孩子一直到家长和领导层。所以我们尽最大努力挑选与教育环境相关的主题，并提供一些心理学的小知识，这些知识无需翻阅数百万本教科书即可应用。
Fantastic. It sounds like a really great resource. Where can people get their ears around that, Adam? You can get it on any of your normal channels, whether it's Apple Podcasts, Spotify, I think we're even on Podbean, I believe. And we, yeah, so you can get us on there, just type it in. And if you follow me on LinkedIn, I am always pushing it. So you'll get a link sent to you and your DMs if you say hello to me. And yeah, so that's where you can find the podcast. And if you want to book a consultation with me, you can get me on my website at www. www.
太棒了。听起来是一个非常好的资源。亚当，人们可以在哪里收听呢？你可以在任何常规渠道收听，无论是苹果播客、Spotify，我想我们甚至在Podbean上也有。所以，是的，你可以在那里找到我们，直接搜索就行。如果你在领英上关注我，我一直在推广它。如果你跟我打个招呼，我会把链接发到你的私信里。所以，这就是你可以找到播客的地方。如果你想预约我的咨询，你可以在我的网站上找到我，网址是 www.
Dr.adam McCartney.com. Fantastic. I will make sure that all of those details are in the show notes and in the description. It's been an absolute delight. It's been really lovely having you on the podcast. and I would love it if people would, you know, spam the comments with love and support for Adam. And if you've got any questions, fling those in there too.
Dr.adam McCartney.com。太棒了。我会确保所有这些详细信息都在节目说明和描述中。这绝对是一次愉快的交流。很高兴你能来参加播客。如果大家能在评论区用爱和支持来“轰炸”亚当，我会非常高兴。如果你有任何问题，也请尽管提出来。
If you'd find a follow-up episode with Dr. Adam and myself, interesting, let us know which area you'd find helpful for us to discuss. Thank you again for your time. I'm wishing you the very best with your podcast, Adam. Thank you. And thank you for having me on. You're so welcome. Oh, my gosh.
如果你觉得我和亚当博士的后续节目很有趣，请告诉我们你觉得讨论哪个领域会有帮助。再次感谢你的时间。祝你的播客一切顺利，亚当。谢谢。也谢谢你邀请我。不客气。天哪，
I honestly feel so energized after my chat with Adam. I feel inspired. I feel hope for the nation's schools. How has it impacted on you? I would love to know. Are you watching this because you work in education or because you want to? Are you watching this because you are working
在与亚当交谈后，我真的感到精力充沛。我感到很受启发。我对国家的学校充满了希望。它对你有什么影响？我很想知道。你观看这个节目是因为你在教育领域工作，还是因为你想了解？你观看这个节目是因为你正在
with children and young people in a clinical capacity or trying to kind of understand what on earth an ed psych does? I would love to know if you found this content helpful. So please do drop us a comment. on YouTube. You can drop any comments or questions on Spotify and I'm on socials everywhere where I am Dr. Marianne Trent. If you learn really well with case studies and vignettes and you are wanting to progress your career in psychology, then I think you'd also really love the aspiring
以临床身份与儿童和年轻人一起工作，还是试图了解教育心理学家到底在做什么？如果你觉得这些内容有帮助，我很想知道。所以请在YouTube上给我们留言。你可以在Spotify上留下任何评论或问题，我在所有社交媒体上都是Dr. Marianne Trent。如果你通过案例研究和片段学习效果很好，并且你想在心理学领域发展你的职业生涯，那么我想你也会非常喜欢“有抱负的心理学家”
psychologist membership. We regularly look at clinical vignettes and thinking about formulating and ways to think around the problem, kind of relevant research, all those kinds of lovely things you can learn more or ask me any questions the details are www.w. Aspiring hyphen psychologist.co. Dot UK and if you're just a big fan of the podcast and the show and of the content I create you can become a member for the podcast which will get you early access either on YouTube or on Apple or you can join it to be able to get exclusive subscriber only content with behind the scenes musings from me.
会员计划。我们定期查看临床片段，思考如何制定方案以及围绕问题思考的方法，还有相关的研究，所有这些你都可以学习的可爱事物。你可以了解更多或问我任何问题，详细信息在 www. Aspiring hyphen psychologist.co.uk。如果你只是播客、节目以及我创作内容的忠实粉丝，你可以成为播客的会员，这将让你在YouTube或苹果上获得抢先体验，或者你可以加入以获得独家订阅者专享内容，包括我幕后的思考。
That is available on YouTube and direct on Apple or on Captivate where I host my show. Thank you so much for being here. Your time in listening to or watching the show is so valued. And I love doing this for you and with you. Love any ideas for future episodes you'd find helpful. You know where I am. With this podcast, that's your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified.
这可以在YouTube上获得，也可以直接在苹果或我托管节目的Captivate上获得。非常感谢你的到来。你收听或观看节目的时间非常宝贵。我喜欢为你和与你一起做这件事。欢迎提供任何你觉得有帮助的未来节目创意。你知道我在哪里。有了这个播客，这就是你的方向，你将走上获得资格的道路。
It's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。